okay is that okay with you please okay
all right
hi everybody uh welcome to our first uh
postlands talk of the of the day
uh we are very very excited to have uh
drew thunderbird
give us a talk
so drew is one of
the world like leading experts
who is a professor of economics at mit
but also like one of the leading experts
on learning in games
he's one of authors of the famous books
in the in the area
and uh we're very lucky to have him and
today he'll be talking about
using learning to predict our first case
cooperation
thanks so much drew and uh you you have
the floor
thank you georgia so thanks to the
organizers for
reading the conference and for letting
us speak on zoom which makes it much
easier and i should say this is joint
work with gustav karskog who's here
and um is happy to answer any questions
in chat so people want to i'm happy to
answer questions myself um with a lot of
time but also if you want to put them in
chat and
zukusta has to say um
that's that'll be great so just a little
introduction
as you uh know
repeated games can have many equilibria
especially when the players are very
patient
what economists
typically do in these situations is
assumed that people play the equilibrium
with the most cooperation or the most
efficient equilibrium
and that's theoretically convenient
but it's a poor fit for what we observe
when we do prisoner dilemma experiments
in the lab
so it seems
um important
for economics to better understand how
cooperation rates in the repeated
prisoner's dilemma
say depend on the parameters of the game
so it's important both for policy and
also as a guide for the development of
more useful theories
so the way that gustav and i approach
this is as a problem in predictive game
theory
meaning we're not going to be so
interested in fitting a particular model
in sample we're going to consider the
problem of predicting cooperation rates
out of sample
using data from experiments on the
prison peter president's dilemma when i
talked about this and related worked
economics audiences i often get pushback
about why do you care about predictions
so i'm happy to discuss that here too my
prior is that this audience is you know
much more predisposed to think
prediction problems are natural um so if
everyone's happy with me
taking that as the goal then i'll
i'll run with it but i'm i'm happy to
discuss that
now or later okay so we are going to try
and fit so that's our goal how are we
going to predict these cooperation rates
well we're going to
write down some learning models
um
that
are very simple and stylized
but are still so complicated that we
don't have closed form solutions for the
cooperation rates so for a given
set of parameters of one of these models
we can run lots of simulations and see
what the cooperation rates look like and
then we can tune the parameters to um
get the best
predictions
so we have a suite of related models i
will discuss
many of them later on we're going to
focus on the simplest one because it
turns out the simplest version of the
model does just about as well as
anything we can come up with
and it only has six parameters and we
like it so you'll see this model is
super simple
it has some learning
um but the learning only affects what
people do in the initial round of each
super game so to
clarify that we look at these
experiments where people go to the lab
and they play these repeated prisons
dilemma with an indefinite stopping time
you play the same partner you know over
and over until the coin comes up tails
or whatever that match ends then you're
anonymously rematched with the new
partner
and
in our model the only thing that people
adjust from their experience is the
probability of cooperating in the very
first round when they're matched with
the new partner okay
we'll that's all show our results help
explain some past findings on the impact
of risk dominance considerations in
cooperation rates and suggest some
modifications to them
some preliminaries
our data comes from other people's
experiments
we start with 12 papers that were
covered in a meta-analysis by double
crochet in 2018
and we added five more papers that were
published since their paper we end up
with 161 different experimental sessions
and over 2 000 participants
in all the experiments in our sample
participants played a sequence of
repeated prisoner dilemma games with
perfect monitoring
and within any session the game
parameters were held fixed so there are
some other experiments where people play
different repeated games in the same
section of the lab we're looking at
sessions where a given subject only saw
one set of parameters
okay there's
in these repeated games
people are randomly and honestly matched
and each round there's a random stopping
time
so what that means is the discount
factor delta of the repeated game
corresponds to the probability one minus
delta that the
playing um ends at the end of this round
but probably one minus delta the game
ends with probably delta it goes on to
the next round and it's the point of
terminology because we're always getting
confusing
confused about this
within a given repeated game we'll talk
about rounds of repeated game
and when people get matched to someone
else we'll say it's a new super game
we're going to
these gains had you know past of all
different scales we're going to
normalize the payoffs so the payoff to
joint cooperation is one
and the payoff the joint defection is
zero so if the payoffs people were given
were their utilities this rescaling is
without loss of generality we're just
dividing by a constant and subtracting a
constant so any
prisoner's dynamic game can be written
in this form
each player has a strategy cooperated
effect
if we both cooperate we both get one
if
row player defects
and column player cooperates rho gets
one plus g
so g is the gain from deviating on a
defecting partner
and the row player gets minus l
it's the loss
okay
so
looking at this uh matrix you'll see one
plus g is more than one and zero is more
than minus l because that was positive
which i should have said so
d is a dominant strategy okay
and we're also
fine
start just reviewing some standard
equilibrium analysis
the outcome
both players cooperated every round
is the outcome of a sub-game perfect
equilibrium
if
one
which is the payoff you get from
cooperating forever
is at least as big as the path you get
by
defecting once and then conforming if
you defect once against a partner who's
uh
playing a grim strategy
you gain one plus g
today but then your best response will
be zero forever after okay so
the little algebra says that cooperation
is the outcome of a sub game perfect
equilibrium if and only if the discount
factor delta is high enough
particularly it has to be
more than the ratio g
divided by 1 plus g
and we'll define that to be delta s p e
for sub game perfect that's the critical
value of a discount factor
that makes cooperation
a sub game perfect equilibrium outcome
key thing
to note
is that the loss l
incurred
when you play c
and your partner plays d
does not enter into this equation
okay
why because if we're starting with a
hypothetical equilibrium where both
people are playing the grim strategy
you never expected a partner to defect
before you do so this this lossless is a
non-issue okay so that's the this
standard classical
game theory calculation
um this
it'd be tempting to conclude that any
time a discount factor exceeds this
critical level people always cooperate
that would be the most efficient outcome
but there's literally no experimental
support for this idea we say little
that's being
generous
other researchers in the past have found
that cooperation in these repeated game
experiments can be better predicted by
measures that reflect some uncertainty
in the players minds
about how their opponents will play
so okay
a bit more set up before we get to our
model i apologize we're almost done with
this setup
so
let me remind you if we have a two by
two matrix game
a strategy is called risk dominant
if it's the best response to your
partner randomizing 50 50. that's just
the definition
now
the repeated game has very many
strategies but we can take the repeated
game and construct an artificial two by
two matrix game with the only two
strategies allowed are grim and always
defect
okay with this and we can look at the
payoffs
in that matrix
and it turns out that grim is risk
dominant in this two by two game
if and only if a discount factor
is
g at least g plus l over one plus g plus
l
okay so if you remember what delta s p e
was that was g over one plus g
we just added a positive number to the
numerator and denominator so we've made
this number closer to one
so this new number
we'll call
delta superscript rd for risk dominant
and the rd difference
which i'll also call size rd because
that's
i have stuck in my head so i
apologize if i if i use those words
instead um
delta rd is defined as
the real actual discount factor delta
minus this critical value
delta rd
so so this this
rd difference cannot priority be
positive or negative there's no reason
to think it's positive in all games okay
so you if you haven't seen this before
you may be very puzzled
but why is he talking about this bizarre
two by two matrix game to analyze a
repeated game
well the reason is that
other people have proposed this measure
and they've shown that it has
something to do with what happens in the
experiments it's a useful composite
parameter of the
underlying
game parameters or
think of it as a feature
a constructed feature for a machine
learning algorithm
the key thing i want you to notice about
this
size rd
is that it depends on the loss l
as well as the gain g
and that makes sense
if people aren't sure
how their partners will play if you're
sure your partner's playing grim
then
your decision about whether to cooperate
or not l just doesn't matter if you're
not sure what they're doing then it
could be risky cooperating because you
risk losing yellows so that's sort of a
uh
intuition for
why this measure might possibly be
useful
okay so that's all sort of background
and setup having
are there any questions yet
okay
so let me talk about what we do
i'm true
sorry this is nicole uh
i i was a little i think i missed
something okay basic which was what is
this
grim in the previous slide you said grim
is
uh randomizing over is the best it's a
strategy is risk dominant if it's the
best response to a 50
50 randomization that's
the opponent is randomizing over the
action space 5050 or the opponent
exactly fix a two an arbitrary two by
two game
suppose your opponent is your opponent
only has two choices by definition
suppose your opponent is is playing each
of their choices equally often
what's the best choice for you
okay
um and so then the second bullet is
saying grim is risk dominant in a two by
two matrix game with with the strategies
grim and always defect i don't
understand what that statement means
thank you for asking
so we it's yes it's a bit terse so
here we have the payoffs
round by round of cooperate and effect
good
the grim strategy says start out
cooperating if your opponent ever
defects defect ever after
so
let's construct the two by two matrix
for grim
and always defect okay if defect plays
itself at all it gets
zero every period so zero on average
right
if grim plays itself it cooperates every
period so it gets one of every round so
the diagonal looks in terms of average
payoff looks exactly the same as as the
matrix we're looking at
now
what happens if it always defect player
playing row
meets a grim player
playing
you know column well the very first
round
role player gets one plus g
and column gets minus l
in all future rounds they both defect
and both get zero
so the
payoff in the lower left-hand corner
in terms of average discounted payoff
for
the defecting player it'll be one plus g
times one minus delta
and for the column player it'll be minus
l times one minus delta
so that's how we build the so we specify
these two strategies we see what that
happens when they play each other and we
look at this as a two by two matrix game
great thanks i can see now if i
there would have been time to
spelled out this matrix but you know i
didn't so thank you for asking
um
any other questions
perfect
so anyway this this whole thing is just
to motivate this this
measure
the rd difference which we're going to
use as a feature in our prediction tasks
is it's just explaining where it comes
from
so we're considered two kinds of
prediction tasks
one is the average cooperation rate in a
whole session
which in a sense is what we really care
about
and the other is predicting the time
path of cooperation how much in the
first round how much in the second round
how much in the third round
one reason that we care predicting time
paths is that's going to let us
extrapolate to what cooperate
cooperation
um i misspoke by time pass i don't mean
round so but the time path i mean the
average cooperation rate in the first
repeated game the second repeated game
the third repeated game
doing that will let us make predictions
about what would happen if
the lab experiments have been much
longer and people played many more
repeated games than they really did
and perhaps
intuitively it turns out that even if
what we care about is predicting the
overall average cooperation rate
predicting the time path and then
looking at the implied average
ends up being a good way to do that
so why this roundabout
um
path
well because if we're predicting the
cooperation level in a session
each of our sessions is a single
observation
and if we predict the time path of
cooperation
a data point is the average cooperation
level round by round throughout the
super game
so i said we had a bunch of different
learning models
i'm going to focus on the simplest one
we call irlsg
for initial round learning
semi-grim
so the initial round learning means that
learning only matters for what happens
when people are rematched so at the very
initial round of each super game that
play will vary with their learning
in all other periods other than the
initial round
play is determined by what's called a
semi grim strategy
so
a semi grim strategy this is a term from
the literature we didn't make it up
the action played only depends on what
happened in the previous round
so it's a particular kind of memory one
strategy
and
okay
why
is interest in the semi gram strategy
well past work has found
support for the idea that most people do
use memory one strategies and our own
machine learning analysis supports this
idea that people are using memory one
strategies
so so
memory one would say what you do today
just depends on what happened yesterday
well there's four things that could have
happened yesterday
both cooperate both defect or one
cooperate one defect
an extra feature of what's called a semi
grim strategy
is that play after cd
is the same as after dc
so what happens if i cooperate and you
defect next round our behavior is the
same as if you cooperated and i defected
moreover we're going to assume that the
same semi-grim strategy is used by all
individuals and all treatments
so we're going to estimate three
parameters to pin down the semi grim
strategy the cooperation rate after cc
the cooperation rate after dd
and the cooperation rate after cd or dc
so that's three numbers
now the learning part
and initial play we allow the initial
round cooperation
in super game s to depend on this rd
difference
and we allow it to depend on each
individual's eyes past experiences e.i
that's where we're learning comes in
and we have a particular functional form
for this so p i initial the probability
that player i cooperates in the initial
round of super game s
is
given by the function in this display
so this
depends on a linear function of the rd
difference alpha plus beta rd
plus this experience or reinforcement
level e i
so you can see we have to estimate
parameters alpha and beta here
to
implement our model
and then it's a final sixth parameter
is the strength of reinforcement so e i
of s okay
is going to be e i of s minus 1 what the
old
experience was
plus
lambda
times what you pay off vi that you got
in pure s minus one times a i
where a i is minus one if you play
defect
in the
initial round of the last super game and
plus one if you played cooperate so if
you played cooperate over the last round
and got a positive payoff
then this ei goes up so your probability
of cooperating
in the initial round next time goes up
how much it goes up depends on this
parameter lambda
so that's the whole learning model
it's
super simple
and it's too simple to be a great
model of any one person's play but the
people at least understand what it is
okay so we have to initialize the system
so we'll say the initial reinforcement
is zero so everyone all individuals
start out exactly the same
and then
what we do we fix the parameters
and we simulate the model
okay
and
we use these simulations as predictions
so
when we make predictions
we don't use endogenous
data as input to simulation we let our
simulation know what the game parameters
were
and how long each repeated game last
lasted
and we then
estimate the model based on the time
path of cooperation
even when predicting average cooperation
so we find the parameters that best
predict the time path of cooperation in
the training set
and use those to predict both average
and time path cooperation in the test
sets and as i said the advantage of this
approach is we use more of the data
so a bit of gloss on how we did this
so we estimate the
model parameters numerically on 10 folds
now
we can
do the estimation
do some simulations
see what the mean squared error is but
then we want to go and tune the
parameters
so
in order to
do this without adding too much extra
noise we hold fixed realizations of the
random variables as we tune the
parameters
and we then standard practice evaluate
models by their 10-fold cross-validated
mean squared error
now this is approach we're using
doesn't have performance guarantees
but it does perform well on simulated
data so we can simulate some data and
see how well our estimation procedure
recovers what we know is going on and in
particular it can distinguish data that
was generated by our irl sg model
from data generated by a popular model
in the literature which is pure strategy
reinforcement learning
an important point you know we say cross
validation there's lots of different
ways of splitting the data
our trained test splits are on the level
of a session
so
we predict play in a given session using
only data from other sessions we think
would be cheating to use to fold in
data from this session into both a test
and a training
fold
okay so that's how we estimate the
parameters but then we'd like to have a
sense of the stability of the estimates
we want standard errors of the estimated
mse
and so we do 10 different 10-fold
cross-validations
so we have 100 different mean squared
errors and that's how we calculate this
standard deviation or standard error of
the mean squared error
so
i told you about our
learning model
and we can see how well it does we want
somebody to compare it to
this performance
so we also used various machine learning
algorithms and ordinary least squares
and we so we actually being gustav um
tried a number of different
approaches lasso support vector
regression gradient boosting trees and
other things that didn't work well
um
and he implemented this in python
okay
and the hyper parameters will matter
like when we do the heterogeneous
models of different types that haven't
even gotten there yet okay
in order to do this machine learning
exercise we have to feed the algorithms
and features
so
for average cooperation we use this rd
difference
which is a composite parameter
the raw parameters delta g and l
the total number of rounds played
the total number of super games played
an indicator function
for whether size rd was positive
and summary statistics
for the difference between the expected
and realized super game lengths right
because if if delta is 7 8 then you
expect the super games to last eight
rounds on average but some will last
more than eight and some will last less
and you know that variance could matter
so we include that
and some interaction terms because you
know
um
obviously not all possible interaction
terms but but a number of them and um
this
little tab that says details is
signaling that if people want to ask
questions about this either now or in
the chat
discussion later there's some extra
information that i'm skipping over for
now about just
what these
features were
when we predict time paths we add the
current super game current round and
indicator this is an initial round
okay so
these three features we thought made
sense again this is something this is
more
bullet point for an econ audience than a
cs audience the
um
point being simply that
with finite data
you can sometimes really help the
machine learning algorithm by feeding it
the right kind of features using domain
knowledge to craft features so we
crafted the features that we thought
were good
of course we can't rule out that
there's some other features we could
have put in that would have made things
much better
anyone has any ideas you know
you can let us know
um so
what
happens suppose our goal is to predict
the average cooperation rate well so the
monkey score is let us predict all
repeated games are the same predict the
average cooperation rate across all of
our data
if you do that
the mean squared error is 0.05
a simple thing that was already in the
literature
is just to do ols
on this rd difference
and you can see that does much better
than predicting constant cooperation
and that's in part the justification the
reason for looking at this rd difference
in the first place is people already
found that it
seemed to have something to do with what
was going on
the support vector regression does even
better than ols
with the mean squared error of o145
but our
irlsg model does even slightly better
than svr which was the best of the ml
algorithms
so
why
is our model doing better than the
machine learning algorithms
well we think it's because
our model better predicts what happens
when the real life super game length is
longer than expected
so
our model predicts there's more
cooperation when the realized super
games are longer than their expected
value
why do you think that's what's going on
well
we gave both the machine learning
algorithms and our model the data of how
long the each super game actually went
if we take that
feature out
from both of the methods they have the
same prediction error so that's that's
that's pretty um seems like pretty
conclusive evidence if that's what's
going on
so
let's
look a bit at the
um actual unpredicted cooperation
so we sort of arbitrarily grouped all of
our repeated games
by their rd difference into five groups
the the bottom purple group is where the
discount factor delta is below the
critical delta spe so there's no
cooperative equilibrium
again the solid purple line is the
actual cooperation rates
super gained by super game in
aggregated over all the experiments
with
delta less than delta s p e
and the dotted line the dashed purple
line is our predicted level so they're
both kind of declining
the next line up the blue line
is where the discount factor delta was
above delta spe
so there is a sub game perfect
equilibrium with cooperation
but delta is less than this risk
dominant level
and here too
we see that the
actual cooperation trends down
and our model predicts it trends down
the
top two curves have higher
values of the highest values of the rd
difference
and both the actual and predicted
cooperation trend up
and this third middle region where the
rd difference is positive but small
both the predicted and average
cooperation are pretty flat
okay so that's that's a
summary of
of of what we see
learning rate we estimate
implies a pretty strong learning effect
particular it implies that about 88
of the between treatment variants
in the cooperation
in the initial round of the very last
beginning of the session is driven by
learning
and not by the rd difference
so this
is a i think an interesting figure may
take longer to parse
so on the
horizontal excess is the rd difference
and
on the vertical
axis is the
difference in payoff people got
depending on whether they cooperated or
defected in the very first round
and you can see
that
cooperating the first round
turns out to be linked with low payoffs
when the rd difference is negative
and it's linked with high payoffs when
the rd difference is positive so that
fits with this idea that
initial round cooperation is reinforced
when the rd difference is the positive
and reasonably large
so each dot in this
graph i should say corresponds to one
experimental session so there are
many sessions with particular values of
this rd difference
for
a negative rd difference
defection is reinforced more strongly
than cooperation in all but one session
that should be one dot here
i guess there's one dot that's right on
the line
um for low but positive values of our d
difference
the difference in reinforcement is
centered around zero
so both cooperating and defecting are
reinforced equally and we think that's
why they're not clear time trends
in the sessions where the rd difference
was positive but small
and our simulations show a similar
pattern
because that's
what happens with the baseline model i
think instead of an arbitrary model and
super simple only six parameters alpha
and beta for the effect of size rd
lambda for reinforcement
and the three
semi-grim parameters so we looked at
three variants that added one parameter
first variant as the recency effect row
where past experiences decay
the second variant
says instead of reinforcing cooperation
when you got a positive payoff
you have some aspiration level tau and
cooperation is only reinforced if your
payoff was more than tau so we can
estimate a towel
another variant we call learning with
memory one that's
no longer semi-grim because we dropped
the requirement that sigma dc
is the same as sigma cd
okay
so all of these are seven parameters
um
here's some yet more complex models
the baseline model
the rd difference only mattered for
initial play
but we could
also let
the
semi-grim strategy this
sigma cc and sigma dd
vary with size rd
so now we have to we have to add more
parameters to do that
or
um
instead of learning only mattering for
what happens initial round we can let
say people play memory one strategies
but what you play after cc you also
learn about how to adjust that
um
or
we could say
there's a separate learning rate for
initial round actions and non-initial
round actions and keep on adding more
and more parameters
okay so that's that's just adding
parameters
another
thing we explored
so our baseline model all agents start
out the same
we could have a model where there's two
types of irlsg agents so
both type of agent use the irlsg agent
but they have different parameters
okay so now we have six parameters for
agent a
and six parameters for agent b
and an extra parameter that says the
shares of agents a and b
okay
or and this is inspired by the
literature a bit we could have two types
of agent one of them
uses our irlsg
and the other defects every round with
constant probability one minus epsilon
so that's that's one parameter epsilon
so why have people who defect almost all
the time because when you look at the
data
the people aren't all the same and some
people do seem to defect almost all the
time
okay
ah
hang with me
one last slide of extra models
so there's a learning model in the
literature from dabo and for shet
where all participants make a noisy
choice between tit for ted and always
defect so they
treat this as a two by two game
and they
do fictitious play with recency on this
two by two game
so their exercise was an in-sample
exercise
we want to you know estimate the model
on some sessions and make predictions on
other sessions
so we have to let the initial beliefs
depend on the rd difference
that has some parameters we also allow
for trembles or implementation errors
people don't necessarily do exactly what
their strategy says
and we consider a reinforcement learning
model with three types tit for tat
always defecting grim
so all the things on this slide are
models of learning pure strategies
and they were the worst models that we
looked at
the more flexible models we looked at
did
a bit worse than our baseline models you
can see that the top three models
are pretty bad
and in fact
the
pure strategy belief learning models do
worse than ols
the reinforcement learning does a little
better than ols
then come a bunch of variants of our
baseline model that add more parameters
okay so all these things have to have
better in sample fit or no worse than
sample fit
but they actually you know overfit
and have worse cross-validated error
and the only thing we could find that
looks
even marginally
better than our baseline irlsg is to
have two types of rlsg
okay oh i should talk a little quicker
um
sorry i have a question what do you mean
by two types
oh good so you're
good thank you so that's that's um on
the top of this slide so there's
we assume every agent in the experiment
is either type a agent or a type b agent
both type of agents follow this irlsg
model that i described before with six
parameters
but
type a agents have
one suite of these six parameters
alpha prime beta prime and so on and the
type b agents have a second suite of a
double prime
beta double prime so it's two
everyone's using the same basic learning
model but some people have
the
parameter set one some people parameter
set two
it's always the case that uh a parameter
uh type a meets a parameter type b right
or never no not at all it's a
homogeneous population people are people
are
anonymously and randomly matched
so it's it's not that a's are playing
b's it's people are playing people we're
going to um
estimate so we don't know for sure who's
an a or b we're going to going gonna see
what
um
what we do is estimate a mixture model
so we say
you know there's a fraction of people
are as a fraction of people are b's
and then let's compute you know the
the error
as a function of this fraction in the
parameters and look for the um
ratio of the
numbers that
minimize the error
okay okay thank you yeah it's it's it's
it's um in in
applied macroeconomics they call these
mixture models they're used a lot in
labor economics
um any rate so it did a bit better than
our model but not so much so um
we want to know what happened if the
experiments ran longer
you know
typically in these experiments pi
doesn't look like an equilibrium but you
might hope if only people played the
experiment for five hours instead of one
would look more like equilibrium so we
could use the learning model to make
predictions by that just say here's the
parameters and simulate what happens
when the game's the session is much
longer
but
we can do that the question is should we
believe the output
so to test if we should believe it
we did something else first
we tested to see
how well we can extrapolate from the
first half of lab sessions to the second
half so we can't extrapolate from the
first half to the second half it's hard
to be confident we could
in our predictions what would happen if
things were 10 times as long
so we're going to take all the sessions
and put each session in a training fold
or a test fold not both
and
we're going to use the first halves of
training sessions
to predict play in second halves of test
sets
so the same
session is not both training and test so
we use the first half
of an experiment in one lab to predict
play in the second half of play in a
different lab
and then we see how well we do okay and
once again there's the
simplest thing to do is
constant
prediction of a second half
of the sessions
we can use support vector machines lasso
ols so here
gradient boost gradient boosting trees
were the best machine learning algorithm
but once again our very simple model did
even better
so the learning model is better at
extrapolating to the second half
of the sessions than the black box
algorithms and you know these mean
squared errors of the errors actually
matter and they tell us this difference
between point 0.0226
is significant
so
why is that well you you could always
think maybe
um we didn't do a good job at the
machine learning and if only you had um
had your own crack at it you could have
you know done much better
maybe but you know also it's sometimes
the case that a more structured model
that encodes some intuition or domain
knowledge can better extrapolate to
related problems that's what we think is
happening here
so
that gives us some hope
um that
we can extrapolate from the data we have
what would happen in much longer
sessions when we do that we see very
wide 90 percent confidence intervals for
the
cooperation rates
for intermediate values of the rd
difference so
here's some plots here
um
it's they're very small i apologize um
but
what we did is we
simulated
um many populations
you know long past
any time we have data
and
what the
three red lines are showing you in the
simulations they're sort of the median
prediction the um
95th percent cooperation in the
five percent
and for these
gains in the middle
what our model says is the long run
outcome cooperation level is highly
stochastic the exact same parameters you
could run the experiment and sometimes
you could end up with like you were
cooperating and sometimes end up with
very few people cooperating
huh
whereas when the rd difference is very
um was negative or very positive then we
end up
both predicting and seeing lots of
cooperation
okay
where is this coming from well it's
partly it's a
finite population and people are mixing
when they meet so there's some
randomness
the more people we have
the smaller the intervals
there's also some randomness because the
super games aren't always their expected
length
um fine so that's that's the summary of
what we've done i i'd like to wrap this
up
fairly quickly because i have a few more
slides we'd really like your feedback on
about some work we hope to do and
haven't yet done so the the summary of
what we've done so far
is the key to predicting cooperation in
a given match
is predicting play in the initial round
and initial round play
depends on the game parameters and on
experience in past matches
and we can predict fairly well and you
can put air quotes on that if you want
with a simple learning model that holds
play fixed except in the initial round
of each super game and only has six
parameters
now
people aren't all the same if you look
at person by person we don't in our
model everyone's the same we don't
believe everyone's the same it's just we
want a a way of making good predictions
now note that our model even though
everyone starts out the same in a sense
there's endogenous heterogeneity because
people will meet different partners who
play different ways have different
experiences and once people have got
different experiences then their future
play will diverge
so in a sense there is endogenous
heterogeneity that comes from learning
a lot past work in this area has assumed
people use fixed strategies without
learning
and you know
found substantial heterogeneity so one
thing we're saying is that neglecting
learning might lead people to over
emphasize heterogeneity
so
we're saying that people don't really
seem to change their play much except at
the initial rounds
does that make sense why might that be
a conjecture is
there's some cognitive cost to learning
and adjusting
so we expect learning adjustment to
happen when the payoff grade gain is
greatest
and we think that's an initial round
so to test this we assumed everyone else
behaves according to our estimated model
and calculated
the potential gain the potential payoff
gained to an agent
from learning and adjustment at all
different histories
so
the best
irl sg model does much better against
these irl sg agents than the best model
without learning
and if we looked at the more complicated
model where people are learning to
adjust their play at every round that
only leads a very small pair of
improvement so so that sort of fits with
this idea people are really thinking
about how to change to be someone new do
they trust them they cooperate or not
that's where the learning goes
because that's what has the most impact
on what happens in the interaction
okay
so the main way this
size rd matters is through the
probability of cooperation in the
initial rounds of each match
initial cooperation trends up or down
depending on whether it's positively or
negatively reinforced
and that depends on this rd difference
turns out our model also predicts that
the values of g and l have an effect
that's not captured by
the rd difference so in the model itself
we just put in the rd difference but
then we went off and did simulations
when you run the simulations it seems
that if you increase the difference
between g minus l
holding g plus l fixed
that doesn't change the rd difference
but it changes our predictions
so
the model says this matters now you say
well okay good you have a new prediction
why didn't you test it well because
there's not enough different experiments
with the same rd difference in different
gl for us to test it
okay
good
um
we also consider the problem of
predicting an individual's next action
round by round traditional history so
far
so that resembles a common approach in
literature
which is to choose parameters of a
structural model to maximize the
in-sample likelihood of all the
decisions
so if people use memory 2 or memories 3
strategies
then access to the preceding three
rounds should help prove predictions but
most of the time people just repeat
their previous actions so most of the
play ends up being cc or dd
okay
yeah i'm going to skip over this because
of of time
um
yeah should i
so
so we have this one step ahead
prediction thing we
did it various ways i think the details
are maybe not so important and neither
of the numbers
um
but here's here's the thing that is
maybe worth noting we can try and
predict play
um round by round
but that gives us very noisy and
unstable predictions of average
cooperation
and
the reason for that is that the
individual actions are easy to predict
a naive model of do we did yesterday
has an accuracy of 87 percent the best
model only 94.
some actions matter a lot more for
predicting the time path
the initial round actions and that's not
captured by these models to try and fit
the action every period
and we say ultimately but what what's
interesting to us at least is is that
aggregate behavior we want to predict
you know what will happen and not the
next action okay
five minutes
um any questions
i realize i've been speeding up so i i
should apologize but i started too slow
and sped up but
what we want to do next is look at
learning in static games not repeated
games
learning in static games with random
matching is well understood
theoretically but it'd be nice to know
more about what's actually going on
the existing experimental literature
employs a method like this
one step ahead prediction task repeated
games what will happen the next time
people play
a number of papers have pointed out
there's a problem with trying to
estimate individual level learning
models in these settings
low power and biased estimates so again
to to explain what's going on people
playing the same
static game over and over
being rematched
they're not playing the same partner not
playing a repeated game
so
if we
estimate these these very if you get
these very noisy estimates of individual
learning models and use that to simulate
populations the generated time paths we
think are unlikely to closely resemble
the actual time paths
so we have work that we're just
beginning with eric moline
that will extend this idea of predicting
accurate time paths to study populations
who play a static game with anonymous
random matching
and
we're going to again simulate many
populations and see what learning model
best matches the observed time paths
so
one thing we could do is look for models
that minimize the meat squared error
which is what we did in the paper i've
just been telling you about
but we think
this the time pass here will be more
complicated and we think it might be
better to use a different method like
approximate maximum likelihood
so we're going to try and do that
there's been a lot of experiments on
repeated uh
play of static games
but not in such a wide set of games and
not all the data from these past
experiments is publicly available so
we're gonna get some new data as well so
that's that's kind of the the plan going
forward
and um
that's that's what i wanted to tell you
but you know we have um lots of time for
questions and discussion so um
thank you very much
questions
so uh i have a i have a
hi drew hi justice hi
good
thanks very much for your talk i was
wondering uh this is very interesting
and i was wondering um
which of these conclusions do you think
generalized to other settings with
repeated play and so on so forth
like uh what like if if i were to design
my uh you know
learning algorithm for a different uh
repeated game you know which of these uh
conclusions i should incorporate in my
in my model
good
so
let's talk a bit about what kind of
repeated games we're thinking of so one
thing you could think about is repeated
games
with imperfectly observed actions all of
the games that we looked at repeated
games if you try and cooperate you
always cooperate
and
there's a
fairly large theoretical literature on
repeated games with imperfectly observed
actions in particular with imperfect
public information so it's as if you try
to cooperate with some probability your
cooperation has misinterpreted this
defection okay
so
there's been
some experimental work on that
[Music]
not enough for us to do the kind of
study we do here because remember for us
basically each each
session is basically one data point or
at most we have one
as many data points as rounds played in
the session
so
we need
our our this i mean our approach
needs many many experiments
and
even
this setting that we do have really
isn't that much data by machine learning
standards they would like even more so
so we can't test what would happen in
these other class of games but there is
one key difference to get right answer
your question so the experiments that
have been done on repeated games with
imperfect monitoring or noise
implementation
suggests that there
people don't use memory one strategies
so instead so memory one strategies um
if you punish someone you punish them
right away someone cheats you once you
retaliate immediately
in
games with these with imperfect
monitoring
then people sort of realize what looks
like it she
could have been a mistake
so people are much more lenient or as
what we called it a paper with uh anna
draper and dave rand people are slow to
anger
so the learning rule we have here
assumes people use memory one strategies
and if i wanted to look at
a similar exercise
in a game with uh implementation errors
i wouldn't think memory one strategies
were a natural starting point we use
them here because people already found
that in this class of games memory one
seemed to be enough
so that's one concrete class of games i
have an answer for you one um what other
kind of repeated games are you
interested in
this is very this is very interesting
yeah
about the complete information games
yeah i was thinking more broadly yeah so
if because you know a lot of work is
modeling learning behavior in games uh
you know typically people think about
ftrl type algorithms multiplicative
weights and so on and so forth and uh
yeah of course here you you think about
the repeated game not uh
[Music]
anyways the the not regret learning
framework but uh yeah i was curious
what is reasonable to bake in a model of
uh behavior in these kinds of settings
it's an excellent question it's very
open you know there's no what we did was
very much ad hoc and so inspired by this
knowledge of
the data told us that memory one was
probably going to be good enough um then
the fact that learning we only needed
learning for the initial round and
nothing else we didn't know that going
in you know so we
ran these other versions that were much
more flexible no more and they ended up
not helping again it's all depends what
you're trying to do if you're trying to
accurately model play of an individual
person our model is hopelessly naive
for that but i guess our point is that
if what you care about is accurate play
you don't need a great model of
what people do round by round what you
need is
is a good model of the key thing which
seems to be this initial round
cooperation
and maybe not the repeated games that
matters too this is what happens the
start of a new relationship has a big
impact i could believe that's a robust
finding but um
you know this is early days
um
at a higher level the the thing that i
think carries over there
hopefully of hoping some people this
audience might you know
like enough to pick it and run with it
is
to view this um
view
these
game through experiments
as a domain
for
making predictions as opposed to for
testing models i think
being able to pred the advantage of a
lab is we can
make lots of data we can compare
um
crane versus test of lots of different
games
and
having models that predict reasonably
well seems like a first it seems like an
important it's not the only criterion
but it
it
it would make me feel much better if we
were better able to predict what happens
in games that seems like a like a good
goal and
it's a
surprisingly hard sell to economists
but
i'm hoping that the computer science
community will find it a more natural um
objective um drew i really enjoyed the
perspective here that at least was novel
to me that what you care about is not
predicting how people play or how they
think about how they play or
understanding how individuals interpret
games but rather how the aggregate
society behaves um i just finished
listening to a podcast about ants which
kind of made the same point like
you can't tell what any individual ant
is going to do but you know what the
hive does
and i i think this is a very
powerful sort of perspective i'm
wondering
how like
it you know
is this really what we want to be doing
when is what is this the salient thing
that that we should understand
it's it's it's not the only thing we
want to be doing i think it'd be great
if we could um you know
really understand exactly how people
learn in games and so on like um you
know
one of the motivations for this work
with eric is
in the context of the
people repeatedly playing a static game
you know the people have tried this
exercise of writing down
very structured learning models
and
seeing how well they do and running
horse races to see whose model fits
better
and
these things
first of all a very low power they can't
distinguish different models
and
most at least most of the past work has
tried
doing this with representative agent
um
models and not these mixture models with
different types of agents
and
that leads to biases so
what we're going to do is step back a
bit and not try to anyone does anything
one person does but but the aggregate
it's an easier problem you know i think
maybe implicit in what you're saying
this is really cool it's a nice thing to
do there's maybe more insight if you
could really understand what makes each
person tick and had a really great model
of each person wouldn't that be better
yeah that'd be great i would love to
have that i guess i've become
that seems hard
um this alternative thing seems
useful
and easier
so
um yes it's nothing so when is it
sailing it is it what we should be doing
it's what some people should be doing
right now me and eric and gustav are
doing it i think more than the three of
us should be doing it i don't think the
entire experimental community should
start doing this
um but you know if
six or eight or ten more people started
doing it
that would be wonderful
so
i had a kind of a similar question i've
been enjoying this discussion
i can't hear you i'm sorry
i had a kind of similar question i've
been enjoying this discussion so i'm
kind of welcoming you to keep on this
but what got you interested in this how
did you get
into this area and this question oh wow
that's that's a that's a good question
so
so i have a long-standing interest in
repeated games
and i had done some past work on
experimental play of repeated games and
and seen how you know
well or poorly the equilibrium theory
that i've been crafting
fits the
data so
that you know those experiments were
done late 2000s early 2010s
and then gustav i was a visiting student
at mit
he was already interested in machine
learning experiments and we started
talking so that's that's that's um
gustav do you have anything more to add
on on sort of the history of thought on
this
uh
i think we also had discussions about
the importance of prediction stuff
because a lot of the models in the
learning literature doesn't seem to
generalize well between games etc yes
that's right that's right so this this
is this is um about the time so
annie liang was here in the audience
earlier that she's had to go off and
teach but
she and i had done a paper on predicting
play in matrix games
trying to use machine learning to
improve level k models so so this this
idea that prediction was a thing but
it's been something that i've personally
been interested in for a long time my
mind before i actually did it i i wrote
like a cheap talk essay about 10 15
years ago called predictive game theory
the nsf asked people to write little
essays and what they thought the field
should be doing and i said we should be
making better predictions at the time i
hadn't actually made any um so sort of
wishful thinking but um
luckily i've you know um
learned
a bit more about machine learning and
i've met some you know fantastic
co-authors who could who could help me
uh do this so um
yeah it's it's
i don't know it's i how did i start
thinking about this but it just seemed
like a natural it's
this frustration
not being able to use the theories i was
developing to make predictions and
thinking wouldn't that be nice
um
that's it seems like a
they're not the only thing one wants to
do with theories you can use them for
your insight and understanding
simplification for counter factuals but
making predictions just seems like such
a natural goal
um so that's that's the high level white
predictions the right prediction
repeated games while working with pt
games games gustaf's interested in
experiments um
yeah that's and that's
and
i don't know that's about all i've got
right now
let's drive anything else
no i think that was a good summary and i
think we also try to kind of develop a
way to do this within this project that
we hope to replicate
uh okay i have a slightly different kind
of question i think um
i believe in the results you ran a
mixture model with like two different
types of agent i was wondering whether
you ran like
you know
k agents k different types of agents um
or
whether that would you know produce
better results out of sample obviously
it would produce better results in
sample um but yeah i was curious why why
stop at only two different types of
agents and do you think that more would
be better et cetera
gusta where do you go
yes
so it becomes computationally intensive
quite quickly the estimation procedure
we use
uh but i'm quite sure we've tried three
at least like two iron lsg and one
always defect and stuff like that
and since we didn't see any improvement
we stopped
i think that if at some point some
improvements you might have continued
but right right i mean we haven't tried
it with 10 types we can't
say for sure wouldn't help but we don't
see any local improvement it's
not much incentive to keep on
keep on going i guess that's that's
that's the extent of it thank you
[Music]
actually i have a question as well
first of all thank you thank you for the
very interesting talk and discussion
uh it's already very promising that like
a relatively simple model that's kind of
like tailor made based on some economic
intuition behaves better than a wide
range of just uh vanilla machine
learning models
uh but have you thought also about
testing you know your
let relatively low dimensional yeah econ
based model versus other models like uh
something like experience weighted
attraction like does that somehow like
that would make would that make sense
and uh
and uh yeah so
so experience weighted attraction on the
on strategies or on action so the
the the way i think you'd have to do
that is
is is to find attractions for strategies
and then in a sense that becomes a lot
like
um
some of the pure strategy
models we tried so i um
mentioned um
a reinforcement learning model where
people play tit for cat always defecting
grim
so that's you take arbitrary three
strategies and reinforce those of ewa
is
i mean
it's it's more flexible it nests
reinforcement learning it respect it
also nest fictitious play
but
we weren't finding the more flexible
models we're doing better and better so
we didn't actually try either we could
do ewa
on tit-for-tat always defecting grimm
um
and
haven't done it
i
really see no reason to think it would
do better i mean
they're just a side note the
um
most of ewa work that's been done these
sports that i know was on a
representative agent model
and
one of the the points of these critiques
of this literature that i want to very
quickly the um
wilcox paper i think in particular says
well if you have heterogeneous agents
different types but you
estimate a
single type agent single type model
then
you will mistakenly you know even if
people are doing fictitious play with
different parameters you will think it
looks like ewa because the
um
what you did
so this regret ends up capturing
is it's a bit complicated
let me not explain it's part of
literature now by saying the so the case
for ewa is much weaker than the original
camera hope papers suggested because
they estimated single agent models
and
part of the
um the pulling towards reinforcement
learning and away from fictitious play
comes from the bias of insisting
everyone's the same
so that's
does not mean
that it doesn't really show that if we
did ewa on
pure strategies here wouldn't do better
i just
might you know
prior is that it's not gonna work but
you know the um
we've put together this data set
and
we'll make it publicly available we'd be
very happy to have people engage in a
you know
contest with us to try
other models and see if they do better
that would be fun
because i mean our model's simple but
you know i
it'd be amazing if we somehow got the
one very best model that that
i
i can't believe we're that lucky
[Music]
sounds good
uh any any last questions
okay uh if not let's uh thank through
again
well
thank you thank the audience for the
question this was lots of fun
good well i'm gonna go have dinner now
so um